what's up fellow artists today we bring  you a full game in Playstations drawn to  death in team deathmatch killing an  enemy gives your team one point and the  first team to ten points will win the  game do you have a favorite character  and drawn to death let us know in the  comments below and for more gaming news  and content be sure to subscribe welcome  to hell you sons of [ __ ]  [Music]  your poxy wake up  [Music]  [Music]  I'm glad it was you  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  your help clear let's get it low  [Music]  tasty  watch your health Blair it's getting low  your worm food your poxy wanker watch  your health player it's getting low  Letta me Jean is one kill from victory  so [ __ ] sucks to be you  [Music]  [Music]